y
[Música]
este es un avance informativo de france
un hombre abofeteó esta mañana el
presidente francés emmanuel mcconnell
sucedió cuando el mandatario se acercó a
unas vallas para saludar a la gente que
lo esperaba en la calle al darle la mano
a uno de los espectadores este lo
cacheteó con la otra mano el hecho
ocurrió durante una visita oficial en el
departamento de otro nombre en el sur
del país el palacio del elíseo confirmó
lo sucedido y dijo que no hará más
comentarios al respecto el equipo de
seguridad de mayor ya tiró al hombre al
suelo y alejó al mandatario tras el
incidente dos personas fueron arrestadas
el presidente estaba en la región para
reunirse con restauradores y estudiantes
con quienes conversó del regreso a una
vida normal después de la pantalla la
identidad del atacante y sus motivos aún
no están claros
los jueces de crímenes de guerra de la
onu confirmaron la condena por genocidio
y la cadena perpetua contra electo ex
comandante militar de serbios de bosnia
ratko la dic el tribunal rechazó la
apelación contra el veredicto de un
tribunal inferior el militar de 78 años
dirigió las fuerzas de los serbios de
bosnia durante la
guerra de bosnia de 1992 a 1995 fue
condenado en 2017 por cargos de
genocidio crímenes de lesa humanidad y
crímenes de guerra incluido el de
aterrorizar a la población civil de
sarajevo durante un asedio de 43 meses y
el asesinato de más de 8.000 hombres y
niños musulmanes en srbrenica en 1995
el consejo de seguridad de naciones
unidas respaldó al secretario general de
la onu antonio guterres para un segundo
mandato
el grupo también recomendó que la
asamblea general de 193 miembros lo
designe por otros 5 años a partir del
primero de enero de 2022 según informó
el embajador de estonia en la onu agregó
que posiblemente la asamblea se reúna el
18 de junio para votar el nombramiento
guterres no tiene oposición oficial de
ningún otro candidato por lo que su
continuidad se da por hecha
en américa latina' tras las
presidenciales del domingo continúa
lentamente el recuento de los últimos
votos en una contienda apretada en la
que el izquierdista peruano pedro
castillo supera a keiko fujimori con más
de 98 mil votos con el 97 como 28 por
ciento de las actas escrutadas castillo
tiene 50 23 por ciento de apoyo y
fujimori retiene 49 77 por ciento
este es el tercer intento de la
derechista por dirigir el país anoche en
rueda de prensa la hija de alberto
fujimori denunció fraude electoral y
esfuerzos de perú libre por anular votos
el banco mundial presentó su reporte
semestral de perspectivas económicas y
dijo que la economía mundial crecerá un
56 % este año lo que supera el 4%
previsto en enero sin embargo el
crecimiento impulsado por eeuu y por
china será de manera desigual en plena
recuperación tras la crisis desatada por
la pandemia se espera que cerca del 90
por ciento de las economías avanzadas
retomen sus ingresos per cápita en 2022
mientras que sólo un tercio de los
mercados emergentes sólo harán el
próximo año en gran medida debido al
acceso desigual a las vacunas
y en una operación internacional contra
grupos que usan comunicación cifrada
fueron arrestadas al menos 800 personas
la agencia europol informó que
registraron más de 700 domicilios que
afectaron a unas 300 organizaciones
criminales 16 países liderados por el
fbi junto a la policía federal de
australia participaron de este operativo
que ha sido considerado por europol como
una de las operaciones policiales más
grandes hasta la fecha estas redes
delictivas tienen una gran demanda de
plataformas de comunicación cifrada para
facilitar sus actividades
hasta aquí este avance siga con nosotros
en france 24 buenos días